ja also wenn man es nicht Spaß machen
würde könnte ich jetzt aufstehen und
gehen
ich glaube nicht dass ich
auf deutsch gesagt zu sehr auf die Kacke
haue
sprechen wir von Musik von irgendwas was
Emotionen liefert oder von irgendeinem
Produkt sprich rote Socken oder deorolle
also ich kann aus meiner persönlichen
Sicht nur sagen dass ich mich nie als
Produkt sehr und wenn ich das Gefühl
habe dass jemand mich dazu machen möchte
dann dann muss ich mich davon
distanzieren
das sind zwar die alten dazwischen aber
diese Grenze ist seit Hannibal schon
lange überwunden und deswegen glaube ich
gar nicht dass Deutschland und Italien
zwei konträre
Instanzen sind zumindest für mich
auch da steuere ich mich dagegen ich
meine es geht gar nicht darum zu sagen
ach ich Marke blond und mindestens eins
75 groß und so soll sie sein das kann
man nicht sagen
das heißt wir können täglich damit
rechnen
also normalerweise so hat man mir gesagt
dauert es mindestens neun Monate okay
ja deswegen
schau mal oder also okay also wir
sollten öfter mal miteinander
telefonieren dann bleibt allerdings
finde wenn man irgendwelche
Fragen ich mache immer auf an den Kopf
geknallt bekommt die jenseits von gut
und böse sind
wann landen sie endlich eine Nummer eins
Hit ja ich hoffe natürlich mit dem
nächsten Titel also ich glaube ich war
mal sehr sehr nah dran